WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So I was able
to come to Anna's
section last week.
And I really enjoyed the
discussion very much.
So I look forward to coming to
all the sections and just
matching the faces to the names
and just hearing your
voice and your ideas.
So it was a great experience
last Thursday.
And once again, just can't
stress enough how important it
is to take advantage of
the writing center.
So today, we're going
to go back.
And I just want to refresh your
memory about some of the
things that we've been saying
about For Whom the Bell Tolls.
Those seven-fold permutations
that we're looking at, in
fact, pretty much
all semester.
And so individual in time,
voluntary versus involuntary,
foreign versus not foreign,
literate versus not literate.
And on Thursday, we were talking
about the distant home
versus the on-site
environment.
And it turns out that there
really are two very distant
homes and maybe just two
homes for Robert.
One is Paris, which isn't
really a real home.
But it is a home in the sense
that it is something that he
has the luxury of taking
completely for granted.
And so that's one definition of
home, a place where he can
work unselfconsciously.
And the other home is a more
complicated place in the sense
that maybe it's not even a
geographical locale, but a
kind of emotional shelter
that is given to him--
bestowed upon him really--
by his grandfather's very
heroic presence
in the civil war.
So it's a nineteenth century
home for him.
And he needs that very much
because of the non-home that
is the twentieth century.
I think that is really a very
sad fact about Robert.
And maybe it's true
of some people.
Sometimes it's true of some
authors that I love that I
feel that they really should
have existed in a different
century, and things would have
been so much easier for them.
Robert isn't exactly that
kind of person.
But there is a sense that the
twentieth century has been
very, very hard on him.
And it is especially hard
on him because of
the fact of his father.
And really, there's no more
central fact than what your
parent was.
So this is the moment that
clears up a lot of things for
us why his own home,
is in some sense, a
non-home for him.
So he got this gun back, his
pistol, that was his
grandfather's pistol from the
Civil War that was misused by
his own father.
And this is what Robert
does with that pistol.
"...he climbed out on the rock
and leaned over and saw his
face in the still water and saw
himself holding the gun,
and then he dropped it, holding
it by the muzzle, and
saw it go down making bubbles
until it was just as big as a
watch charm in that clear water,
and then it was out of
sight."
This is the best that he can do
for his father is to make
his father disappear.
The extent of the contamination
that his father
has brought upon the memory of
his grandfather can be washed
clean only when he becomes
no more than a bubble.
And then not even a bubble
anymore in that clear water.
It clearly goes back to
Hemingway's conception of
cleanliness, of how one clears
up one's life in In Our Time
in the Big Two-Hearted River.
But I think that also within
For Whom the Bell Tolls, it
also looks forward to a moment,
a traumatic moment,
when someone else is looking at
something like a mirror and
seeing his own reflection.
And I just want to call your
attention to the very
deliberate composition of this
particular visual tableau.
Robert isn't just dropping
the gun.
He has to go up there.
He has to see his own face.
He has to see himself
holding the gun.
And it's that kind of almost
narcissistic observation of
himself that Hemingway is really
fascinated by, and the
psychological meaning of that.
So we can read all kinds
of meaning into
this particular scene.
And we'll see it repeated by
another person in an equally
traumatic moment.
But here, it seems that Robert
really has no parent.
He looks at the world, and
the only thing that
he can see is himself.
It's almost as if he's really an
orphan, has always been an
orphan all the time, because his
father can't really be a
father to him.
And so the act of dropping the
gun is, in some sense, only a
redescription of what
has long been a
psychological fact for Robert.
So all this highlights the fact
of how important it is to
die well, not just for yourself,
but also for other
people for whom your death would
also be consequential.
And here, the biography
of Hemingway really
becomes quite important.
Hemingway's own father, Dr.
Clarence Hemingway, died by
his own hand.
And we know that Hemingway
himself also
died by his own hands.
So in many ways, For Whom the
Bell Tolls is kind of a
meditation ahead of time to
that moment when Hemingway
would have to decide what
to do with his own life.
And so this was front page news
in the New York Times,
June 3, 1961.
Front page news, Chicago
Tribune.
And on July 3, 1961, the
interpretation of the death of
Hemingway was that it
was accidental.
He was cleaning his gun, and the
gun just kept going off.
And this fiction lasted for five
years, until 1966, when
his widow, Mary Hemingway,
finally admitted that no,
actually that he had just put
the gun into his own mouth and
blew out his own brains.
So it took five years for
the truth to come out.
And now there are all
kinds of theories.
In fact, just last summer--
I think it was July-- there was
a lot of speculation that
Hemingway might have died
because he was under such
close surveillance by the FBI.
So that's just a new theory that
would still be coming up
in 2011, so many years
after the death.
People still continue to have
conjectures about why it was
that Hemingway killed himself.
But I think that one simple
explanation is that he was
just in very, very
poor health.
And he was not able to write.
And I think that for a writer,
there probably is nothing more
painful than that, or something
that would make life
more meaningless than not
being able to write.
So this is a picture of him
fairly close to the end.
And this was a public
appearance.
So he wasn't looking too bad.
But we can sort of see that he
really wasn't looking well.
And he was there.
It was a fishing competition.
And Castro apparently won
lots of trophies.
And Hemingway was there to
give him the trophies.
But he really wasn't
looking well.
So I think that that probably
is the simplest explanation,
that he no longer is
what he once was.
And he simply couldn't accept
the fact that there is this
kind of sharp decline in
his mental abilities
and physical abilities.
So this is the last
image that I like
to show you of Hemingway.
It's just where he
used to write.
And that is the most important
place for him, really, in the
whole world.
And today, we'll talk about the
thinking about that, about
how he ended his life.
We'll think about the varieties
of dying and the
numerous ways by which
people end or choose
not to end the life.
So Hemingway actually covers
the entire spectrum--
people who choose to die as well
as people who choose not
to die and seeing what it
means in each case.
So we'll begin by looking at the
central event in For Whom
the Bell Tolls, the execution
of the fascist.
And then we'll look at the
personal end or non-end of
various individuals, beginning
with Finito whose name
obviously is a pun.
And then the old women in the
Madrid market, in the bombing,
which is a new phenomenon in the
early twentieth century.
And then Robert's
father again.
And then Pablo, someone
who refuses to die.
But first of all, the execution
of the fascist. We
should remember this whole,
very long episode
is narrated by Pilar.
So I hope that you guys will
talk about it in section what
it means for a woman who's on
the Republican side to be
recounting this story, the
execution of her political
enemies and how she feels about
this, and why it is that
Hemingway chooses to have
a woman tell this story.
So anyway, this is Pilar
speaking, and how the
Republican guerrillas have taken
the town, so they can
execute all the fascists.
And this is all engineered
by Pablo.
"He placed them in two lines as
you would place men for a
rope pulling contest or as
they stand in the city to
watch the ending of a bicycle
road race with just room for
the cyclists to pass between,
or as men stood to allow the
passage of a holy image
in a procession.
Two meters was left between the
lines and they extended
from the door of the
Ayuntamiento clear across the
plaza to the edge
of the cliff.
So that, from the doorway of
the Ayuntamiento, looking
across the plaza, one coming out
would see two solid lines
of people waiting."
For Pilar, this formation, this
particular visual tableau--
and once again, it's
highly visual--
is emphasizing what one will
see coming out of the
Ayuntamiento.
It's two solid lines of people
who are very, all the way, not
inflamed by passion, just doing
what needs to be done.
And so all the metaphors that
Hemingway uses are actually
ritualistic metaphors, something
that is extremely
well-defined or very
well-defined rules of the
game, like rope pulling contests
or better yet,
bicycle race.
Not considered a violent
event, either of those.
But it still more intensifying
the degree of ceremoniousness
is the procession of
the holy image of
an icon going through.
So the three metaphors highlight
the fact that there
is the equivalent of those
rituals, civic and religious
rituals, that would be a
political ritual of execution.
At it's most utopian --
the execution of your opponents,
which is a
necessary thing in
some cases --
the execution of your political
opponents should be
as ritualistic, as ceremonious,
as free of
passion, as all those other
ritualistic events.
So this is a very utopian
moment in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
And if it could be held at this
level, then the Spanish
Civil War, according to Pilar,
would in fact be a good war or
a beautiful war.
And she tends to think of
those terms as sometimes
synonymous, and we'll
talk about that.
But in any case, it begins
with a very utopian
description of what a war could
be and what you could do
to your enemies without debasing
them, without abusing
them, even though you
do kill them.
And I tried to find an image
of the two lines of people,
with the people who are being
executed passing through.
And I just couldn't find
an image, I guess.
It's not surprising.
Probably nobody will be taking
pictures at that moment.
But as it turns out, one major
artist actually has numerous
paintings that seem
to be alluding to
that kind of formation.
And it's Robert Motherwell,
a major twentieth century
artist. And not only does
he have one, he
actually has numerous.
From the '50s on to the '70s, he
produced numerous paintings
all called Elegy to the Spanish
Republic with this two
line formation.
So this is an early one
that was found in, I
think it was 1954.
And this one is much later.
He numbers all of them.
This one is in the Metropolitan
Museum.
And this one is 102, I don't
actually remember what date it
was, but obviously later.
And this one is quite
late in the '70s,
110 now in the series.
And it's in the Guggenheim
Museum.
So clearly, Hemingway's talking
about something that's
also recognized by other people
as, in many ways, kind
of the utopian moment of the
war when violence is both
executed, but not allowed
to get out of hand.
But Hemingway also shows us
that, in fact, that is not a
sustainable Utopia.
That violence kept within
limits, violence kept within
bounds, is not likely to
last for the whole
duration of the war.
So Pilar refers to this
as drunkenness
coming into the lines.
".,..the people of this town
are as kind as they can be
cruel and they have a natural
sense of justice and a desire
to do that which is right.
But cruelty had entered into the
lines and also drunkenness
or the beginning of drunkenness
and the lines were
not as they were when Don
Benito had come out...
in Spain drunkenness, when
produced by other elements
than wine, is a thing
of great ugliness."
So already we're beginning to
see the language of beauty and
ugliness coming into the
situation where it seems that
moral judgment is in play.
So Pilar's referring to real
drunks, actual people who are
drunks in that episode.
But she's also referring to
another kind of drunkenness,
which is to be drunk with maybe
the desire for vengeance.
Drunk with your own sense of
momentary power, absolute
power over someone.
Drunk with your ability to
bring about absolute
debasement in your opponent.
All of those things can make
people inebriated.
And so Hemingway's really
talking about and Pilar is
talking about different forms
of inebriation and how they
can all work to break down the
stability, orderliness, and
ceremoniousness of what
really ought to be
no more than a ritual.
So it's the breakdown of ritual
that for Pilar marks
the beginning of the chaos and
the mob violence that takes
over the scene.
So just because we're talking so
much about-- she just talks
about ugliness.
And in many ways, she's inviting
us to think about
both the ethics, but also the
aesthetics of killing.
A book that is pertinent to
that kind of thinking is
Elaine Scarry's book On Beauty
and Being Just. And her
argument is that beauty is
actually very important in our
consideration of justice.
That the sense of proportion,
the sense of balance, the
sense of symmetry, all those
ideas that we associate with
beauty should also be concepts
that we consider when we think
about crime and punishment.
Whether the punishment is
commensurate with the crime.
So it's a very interesting
argument.
And not really just about
execution of political
prisoners, but thinking about
justice in general.
So just keep that in mind as we
go with Pilar to talk more
about the breakdown
of the line.
"Then some drunkard yelled,
'Guillermo!' from the lines,
imitating the high cracked
voice of his wife and Don
Guillermo rushed toward the man,
blindingly, with tears
now running down his cheeks
and the man hit him hard
across the face with his flail
and Don Guillermo sat down
from the force of the blow and
sat there crying, but not from
fear, while the drunkards beat
him and one drunkard jumped on
top of him, astride his
shoulders, and beat him with a
bottle."
My reading is not even doing
justice to just how horrendous
this scene is.
And I think that the reason that
Hemingway really singles
out this moment is, in fact,
incommensurability between the
punishment and the crime.
We know in fact--
and Pilar is very careful
to tell us--
that Guillermo is not the
worst of the fascists.
In fact, he's not rich.
He doesn't own anything.
He owns a wooden implement
little shop.
He is a fascist because
of his wife,
because his wife is religious.
And so he just becomes a
fascist to humor her.
So he really is the last
person who ought to be
executed under those
circumstances.
And he's also the last person
who ought to be humiliated in
this particular way.
There's various kinds
of execution.
There doesn't have to be this
kind of very brutal kind of
debasement of the person that's
just very cruel mockery.
This is really what Pilar means
that these people are
naturally kind, but they're also
capable of great cruelty.
And this is the moment when we
see that cruelty dramatized.
So it's not even the killing
of Guillermo.
It's the making fun of him.
And just the whole treatise, the
scenario engineer in such
a way as to bring about the
maximum degradation on the
part of Guillermo.
This is what makes this
scene so unbearable.
And so for Pilar, this is the
absolute low point maybe of
the whole Spanish Civil
War up to that point.
Although she can't look into
the future, and she doesn't
know what's to come.
But in any case, this is the
moment when all of a sudden,
everything seems to be
going the wrong way.
And it is a turning point
for the worse for Pilar.
"'I myself had felt much emotion
at the shooting of the
guardia civil by Pablo,' Pilar
said. 'It was a thing of great
ugliness, but I had thought if
this is how it must be, this
is how it must be, and at least
there was no cruelty,
only the depriving of life,
which as we all have learned
in these years is a thing of
ugliness but also a necessity
to do if we are to win, and to
preserve the Republic.'"
So it's a very complex bit
of reasoning here.
And it seems that
Pilar's actually
disagreeing with Scarry.
So Scarry thinks that there's
almost kind of a perfect match
between beauty and justice.
That in our mind's eye--
not so much in the physical
eye, but in our
mind's eye in our mind--
what we recognize in our mind's
eye as beautiful will
also be just. That
there's that kind
of balance and symmetry.
But Pilar's making a distinction
between something
that is ugly and something that
is morally reprehensible
and something that is
politically necessary.
So those are the three
kinds of
concepts that are in
play in her head.
And for her, something that is
politically necessary can also
be ugly, and that is OK.
So she can take ugliness.
She doesn't welcome it.
She doesn't love it.
But she can take it.
It is the cruelty that
she can't take.
And so based on that
distinction, it is the fact
that cruelty had entered
into the lines.
For her, that is the measure of
just how much the sense of
war has been corrupted
from within.
That basically it
has gone bad.
And that is a phrase that
Hemingway uses quite a bit in
For Whom the Bell Tolls.
Pablo is someone who
has gone bad.
And the Spanish Civil War, the
Republican cause is something
that has gone bad.
So the final reflection
from Pilar.
"...but I could not sleep that
night and I got up and sat in
a chair and looked out of the
window and I could see the
square in the moonlight where
the lines had been and across
the square the trees shining
in the moonlight, and the
darkness of their shadows, and
the benches bright too in the
moonlight, and the scattered
bottles shining, and beyond
the edge of the cliff where
they had all been thrown.
And there was no sound but the
splashing of the water in the
fountain and I sat there and I
thought we have begun badly."
So she's arriving at that, which
for her, is the ultimate
really judgment.
Not ugly, but bad.
That this is her verdict
on her own side.
So Pilar, of course, is not
speaking for Hemingway.
But I think that she has
a lot of authority.
And so her pity is
something that we
should take very seriously.
At what point does cruelty
in any war--
not just the Spanish Civil War
but the first World War, the
second World War especially
is a war
marked by great cruelty--
at what point does cruelty
render that side not
justifiable any action?
Even winning is maybe
not justifiable.
So from there, from this kind of
a large-scale meditation on
the justice of war -- whether
there could be a just war --
or at what point does all
wars become unjust --
From that large scale macro
meditation, let's move on to
thinking about dying as a much
more personal phenomenon and
also a choice, quite often.
Hemingway is very interested
both in people dying
involuntarily, but also in
people choosing to live on
voluntarily, even though living
on might not be a very
beautiful thing.
Might not even be actually an
ethical thing, although that
is kind of a funny
thing to say.
But he certainly seems to be
really thinking about looking
forward to his own end in the
Agustin episodes, but
beginning with the bullfighter
Finito.
So this is someone
who is already--
his career is over
at this point.
He's gone to his last corrida,
last bullfight.
And this is the ceremony
celebrating the end of his
career and his retirement
and his glorious
career up to this point.
"Finito did not eat much because
he had received a
palotaxo, a blow from the flat
of the horn when we had gone
in to kill in his last corrida
of the year at Zaragoza.
So the president of the Club
reached the end of the speech
and then, with everybody
cheering him, he stood on a
chair and reached up and untied
the cord that bound the
purple shroud over the head.
And the head of the bull was as
though he were alive, his
forehead was curly as in life
and his nostrils were open and
his eyes were bright
and he was there
looking straight at Finito.
Everyone shouted and applauded
and Finito sunk further back
in the chair and then everyone
was quiet and looking at him
and he said, 'No, no,' and
looked at the bull and pulled
further back and then he said,
'No!' very loudly and a big
blob of blood came out and he
didn't even put up the napkin
and it slid down his chin and
he was still looking at the
bull."
There's a lot of looking
in Hemingway.
You guys can write a great paper
just by looking at the
dynamics of looking.
Sort of the gaze that we cast
upon someone else and
sometimes the gaze that
they cast back at us.
Quite often it's a kind of
a reciprocal process.
And here it is indeed a
reciprocal process.
Finito is looking at the
bull, and the bull
is looking at him.
Even though it's a dead bull,
it doesn't matter.
A dead bull can look
back at you too.
And it seems that here,
actually, it is not what
Finito is seeing.
It's not the mirror image.
And that's what's so
heartbreaking about it.
It would have been great if it
had been a mirror image.
Because what he sees in a bull
is actually a bull in a full
vigor of life.
This bull, even though it's
dead, he's more alive than
when he was alive, it seems. His
curly hair, his nostrils
are open, his eyes are bright.
He's just a great spectacle.
And more than that,
he's animate.
He seems to be endowed with
life even after death.
And so if this were a mirror
image, this ought to have been
Finito in his prime of life,
when he was a great matador,
when he wouldn't be coughing
blood, when he would be able
to eat instead of now when he
can't eat anything, because of
the damage that has been
done to this stomach.
So if this were a mirror image,
Finito would have been
young again.
But we all know that that's
not going to happen.
And so Hemingway is clearly
punning on the word Finito.
This is a man who is finished.
When a man is finished in this
particular way, is it better
or worse for him to
be still alive?
Wouldn't it have been better if
he had been killed earlier,
just like the bull?
Then he would have been
preserved at the maximum high
point of his life.
So I think it's not the kind of
thinking that actually we
want to engage in
all the time.
But it is something that I think
that Hemingway takes
very seriously, obviously.
And so for him, this is
a kind of comic --
tragic-comic moment
of survival.
Yes, Finito is hanging
on there.
He's not about to just dispatch
himself voluntarily.
He's going to hang on.
But it's a very dubious
kind of hanging on.
And the only redeeming thing
that we can say about it is
that it is funny.
It's comical.
So once again, the only way that
we can take this, we can
swallow this, stomach it, is by
saying that it is a comical
moment in For Whom
the Bell Tolls.
And there's another equally
tragic-comic, obviously mostly
comic moment in For Whom the
Bell Tolls about somebody
hanging on, refusing to die,
even though they have
finished, as Finito
is also finished.
This is Pilar talking
to Robert about
the smell of death.
And then he doesn't know
what that smells like.
And she tells him to go to
the market in Madrid.
"'You must go down the hill in
Madrid to the Puente de Toledo
early in the morning to the
matadero and stand there on
the wet paving when there is a
fog from the Manzanares and
wait for the old women who go
before daylight to drink the
blood of the beasts that
are slaughtered.
When such an old woman comes out
of the matadero, holding
her shawl around her, with her
face gray and her eyes hollow,
and the whiskers of age on her
chin and on her cheeks, set in
the waxen white of her face as
the sprouts grow from the seed
of the bean, not bristles
but pale sprouts in the
death of her face.
Put your arms tights around her,
Ingles, and hold her to
you and kiss her on the mouth
and you will know the second
part that odor is made of."
I definitely think there's
quite a bit of
misogyny going on.
Old people, male and female
kind of look bad.
But Hemingway seems completely
fixated on how
bad old women look.
And especially the bean sprouts
growing on her face --
I think that's why it's
sort of comic and is
OK because of that.
Actually, lots of very well
known older women have this
kind of whiskers on the faces.
And it's just a fact.
But for Hemingway, it seems to
be a kind of a reproach on the
old women that they
should have this
growth on their faces.
And that, in many ways, they are
going against nature, that
suddenly they have become men
rather than women to have
whiskers on their
faces and so on.
And so they really ought to have
died earlier instead of
allowing this unnatural
phenomena to happen to them.
It's really a very small
incident, but nonetheless, the
female counterpart to
the Finito story.
And I just want to stop here for
a moment and talk a little
bit about the interconnections
between Hemingway and
Fitzgerald.
In fact, we've seen this
phenomenon before of a kind of
an unnatural growth that is
almost a parody of nature.
So we've just had this
tragic comic bean
sprouts on a human face.
And actually in Fitzgerald, we
have a kind of non-comic
version of that in The Great
Gatsby in the Valley of the
Ashes with the ashes
growing like wheat.
And I'll read you the
passage in a moment.
But Hemingway also has the kind
of non-comic parallel to
the Fitzgerald version, which
is also a kind of parody of
nature that we'll look at.
But first, something that is
almost like the market scene
of the bean sprouts in
The Great Gatsby.
"This is the valley of ashes,
a fantastic farm where ashes
grow like wheat into ridges
and hills and grotesque
gardens."
So Fitzgerald's talking about
some kind of grotesque
vegetation that is made up of
the animate and the inanimate.
And in many ways, Hemingway's
talking about exactly the same
thing, the bean sprouts.
The women are almost
inanimate.
They really ought
to be inanimate.
It's a caricature of the animate
that they are animate.
But in any case, it is sort of
the re-commingling of the
animate and the inanimate that
he's talking about and that
Fitzgerald is also
talking about.
So just really curious that the
organic and inorganic are
mixed in this way for
both authors.
I would say that for Fitzgerald
this is very hard
to see this as comic at all.
He didn't try very hard.
But this is just
not that funny.
It's ominous.
It refers to a tragedy.
But Hemingway also has a
completely non-comic parallel
to that of something that is
almost a parody of nature,
except that it doesn't take
the form of bean sprouts.
It is a human invention that
looks like the work of nature,
but there's something else.
So there's another bombing of
the El Sordo band on the top
of the hill.
They've been chased to the top
of the hill, and they're
basically kept there by the
firing power of the enemy.
And they're on the top of the
hill, so they're just being
bombed, the maximum point of
efficiency from the bombs.
"Then, through the hammering
of the gun, there was the
whistle of the air splitting
apart and then in the red
black roar the earth rolled
under his knees and then waved
up to hit him in the face and
then dirt and bits of rock
were falling all over and
Ignacio was lying on him and
the gun was lying on him.
But he was not dead because the
whistle came again and the
earth rolled under him with the
roar then they came again
and the earth lurched under his
belly and one side of the
hilltop rose into the air and
fell slowly over them where
they lay."
Supposedly it is bombs
dropped by all those
bombers that we saw.
The Heinkos and the Fiats, the
German Heinkos and
the Italian Fiats dropping
the bombs.
In this case, I think it's
just the Italian bombers.
But the way that this moment of
bombing is described three
times in this passage is that
the earth is rising up and
hitting the guerilla band and
every one of them gets killed
in this bombing.
It is the fact that the earth
seems to be conspiring with
the bombers and hitting the
human beings that it has
nurtured all this time.
That is the ultimate insult.
That's the ultimate injury.
That the Spanish peasants,
they live on the earth.
They think that the earth
is on their side.
And to have the earth suddenly
joining the side of the enemy
is about the worst thing
that could happen.
And so this is the cruelty of
the description of that scene.
A cruelty that is very much
coming from Hemingway himself.
He didn't have to describe the
bombing as the action of the
earth rising up and hitting
all these human beings.
He doesn't have to describe
them in this way.
He's describing the incident
in this way deliberately to
highlight the fact that in
which nature has been
perverted by human action.
That modern technology has
perverted nature so that
nature is no longer a
place where human
beings can be nourished.
It's that nature is something--
the earth itself
is a weapon that can be used
against human beings.
And what is also cruel about
this particular realignment of
the earth with the enemy is
that it reaches back, and
retrospectively and
retroactively rewrites and
ironizes an earlier moment.
Because this is not the first
time that we hear about the
earth rolling or the
earth moving.
In fact, one of the most famous
little detail from For
Whom the Bell Tolls is that
when you have good sex
supposedly the earth
moves under you.
And this is what Pilar
wants to get.
The information that Pilar wants
to get from Maria to
make sure that everything is
fine, that this, in fact,
happened.
"'The earth moved,'
Maria said, not
looking at the woman.
'Truly.
It was a thing I cannot tell
thee...' 'For you, Ingles?'
Pilar looked at Robert Jordan.
'Don't lie.' 'Yes' he said.
'Truly.' 'Good,' said Pilar.
'Good.
That is something.'"
So this is back in page 174.
The earth moving, it's all
on the human side.
And for someone who has
a very short life--
everyone seems to know that
Robert might actually have a
very short life--
for someone who's going to have
a very short life, having
that experience is
very important.
So on page 174, the earth moving
has one connotation.
And the cruelty of what happens
on page 331 is that it
completely rewrites that earlier
scene and assigns a
completely different-- in fact
the opposite-- meaning to the
earth moving.
So this is what Hemingway's
sometimes quite brutal
narrative can do, is that even
something that seems to be
safely concluded --
that earth moving for
Robert and Maria --
even though that is safely
concluded in the past, it is
actually not safe from a
subsequent rewriting and a
reassignment of meaning.
So that the meaning of the earth
moving clearly is in
flux maybe.
Maybe it could be either way.
Or maybe, the later event
actually can completely erase
the earlier meaning.
I think we have to decide for
ourselves to what extent page
321 can undo that earlier
Utopian moment.
I want to talk about two other
things that are associated
with dying and not dying,
both hinging on the
word "cobarde," coward.
The first actually goes back
to Robert's father.
But when we're looking at the
scene when he's just dropping
the pistol in the water, there's
no description of how
he feels about his father.
It's just that he wants
to get rid of the gun.
He never wants to see
the gun again.
That's it.
He's managed to get
rid of the gun.
But actually, there is an
upfront description of how
Robert feels about his father
and also a clarification of
why he needs his grandfather.
"Aw hell, I wish grandfather
was here, he thought.
For about an hour anyway.
Maybe he sent me what little I
have through the other one
that misused the gun.
Maybe that is the only
communication that we have.
But, damn it.
I'll never forget how sick it
made me the first time I knew
he was a cobarde.
Go on, say it in English.
Coward.
It's easier when you have it
said and there is never any
point in referring to a son of
a bitch by some foreign term.
He wasn't any son of
a bitch, though.
He was just a coward and that
was the worst luck any man
could have."
This is interesting for
multiple reasons.
One is that Robert really hopes
that he's the grandson
of his grandfather, rather than
the son of his father.
That's really clear.
And because both actually
describe him, he is both his
grandfather's grandson
and his father's son.
If he had the choice, he would
much rather be the former.
So he's suddenly hoping for the
best, which is that his
father would just disappear
and that one
link would be invalid.
It would be an invalid link.
But the way that he thinks
about his father is--
first of all, that this is a
moment when Spanish seems to
come in handy.
That maybe it's easier just to
ease your way into that way of
thinking about your father.
So you go by way of a
foreign language.
But then you really have to
say it in your own tongue.
But then the way that he thinks
about that word is
actually too empty of
any moral judgment.
I think that when we use the
word coward, we tend to attach
a lot of moral significance
to that term.
Lack of bravery is a kind of a
moral failing on the part of
the person who's lacking
that quality.
But finally Robert is just empty
of that moral judgment
and just saying that some
people are just unlucky.
Some people are just born
not very brave. And it
is not up to them.
If they are born not very
brave, it is too much to
expect absolute bravery
from them.
They're not meant to be brave.
And when they are tried under
certain circumstances, when they
can't meet that test of
bravery, then they're
going to break.
So this is his way of accounting
for the fact that
his father can't live
on stubbornly--
doesn't have the will to live,
to keep him going--
just to make sense of that
in his own mind.
So in this incident, a coward's
decision to die is
rendered acceptable.
It's still not a great thing,
but he can wrap
his mind around it.
And that's really what he wants
to do is to be able to
wrap his mind around the fact
of his father's suicide.
But I think that Hemingway
actually--
and this really speaks to how
far he's able to imagine a
position that in the end we know
that will be the opposite
of his own--
how far he's able to imagine
and give dignity or maybe a
kind of admiration to someone's
decision not to die.
The stubborn decide to hang on
and not just to go right now.
And so parallel to that,
symmetrical to this, but also
antithetical to his father's
action is a
cobarde's will to survive.
And the person who embodies that
will to survive is Pablo
whom I argue is actually one
of the most interesting
characters, arguably more
interesting than Robert in
this novel.
Because so much goes on inside
his head an also through him
that we actually don't see
represented in the novel.
So this is one area where
Hemingway even alerts us to
the fact that there is
some information
that we're not getting.
And that lack of information
or that non-disclosure of
information actually makes
Pablo the very mysterious
person that he is.
Anyway, Pablo is close to being
killed at this moment.
"Agustin hit him again hard in
the mouth and Pablo laughed at
him, showing the yellow, bad,
broken teeth in the reddened
line of his mouth.
'Leave it alone,' Pablo said
and reached with a cup to
scoop some wine from the bowl.
'Nobody here has cojones to
kill me and this hand is
silly.' 'Cobarde,'
Agustin said.
'Nor words either,' Pablo said
and made a swishing noise
rinsing the wine in his mouth.
He spat on the floor.
'I am far past words.' Agustin
stood there looking down at
him and cursed him, speaking
slowly, clearly, bitterly and
contemptuously and cursing as
steadily as though he were
dumping manure on a field,
lifting it with a dung fork
out of a wagon.
'And thou!
And thou!' Agustin turned from
the door and spoke to him,
putting all this contempt into
a single, 'Tu.' 'Yes, me,'
said Pablo. 'I will be alive
when you are dead.'
So Agustin is trying his best
to get Pablo into a fight so
that he can be killed right
then and there.
And Pablo is doing everything he
can to stay alive, and he's
succeeding.
So no question about it, he's
an excellent coward.
He's going to stand there and be
insulted maybe for as long
as Agustin has breath
to insult him He's
not going to break.